[Music]
three two one action hey guys welcome
back to off-the-record where we talk
about whatever we what Oh today we also
have a brand deal in a sponsor thank you
very much
top start is the online lending market
place that provides personal loans using
non-traditional variables such as
education and employment to predict
credit worthiness creditworthiness he's
a crazy worthy this is basically you
know like how much you have in credit
and stuff like that so upstart believes
you're more than just your credit score
they believe in you and they understand
that they make it fast simple and easy
to check your rate in just a few minutes
the best part is that most people who
are approved to get their funds the very
next business day yeah that's crazy yes
and over three hundred thousand people
have used up start to pay off credit
cards or achieve their financial goals
already for yourself from the burden of
high interest credit card debt by
consolidating everything into one
monthly payment with upstart CY upstart
is ranked number one in their category
with over three hundred businesses on
Trustpilot and hurry to upstart dot-com
slash record to find out how low your up
start rate is checking your rate only
takes a few minutes and won't affect
your credit so click in the description
box below for that link and I think I'm
actually gonna do this because I want to
consolidate some credit cards got about
thirty thousand dollars that I need to
pay back and I rather have upstart do
this for me I am I am using this to open
up a loan to start finally start my claw
machine business yep those claw machines
they [ __ ] destroy a ring oh you mean
like at the arcade yeah like human-sized
like yeah the big ones I'm gonna buy I'm
gonna buy a machines yes you can't yes
I'm all take I'm taking vessels follow
me and we're going and I'm gonna set the
Machine up so that it never [ __ ] ever
wins but everything in there is the
tightest [ __ ] you ever tried in your
life like [ __ ] like a gold claw so
clapping it
picking up a gold clock but it's a goal
that's so meta
right it's gonna be actual [ __ ] like
iPads or laptops or something yeah but
that's what everyone already does he's
not very well though I've never seen a
machine with iPads in yeah and in Japan
some of those we yeah in Japan they the
claw machines is like the arcade or like
the casino where they have really dope
stuff like Dobby straight up like
blenders and stuff into it had the
actual planner in there cuz that be
[ __ ] up wouldn't it be [ __ ] up if
it's in a box could never get it no
there's like all kinds of weird things
and then people know how to like trick
the machine to like push it over you
don't use the claw you just I'm just
gonna put my kid in there and have him
going that's pretty good would your kid
get caught I've been good how about you
I used to just yeah but you already here
for me enough I think we all do Jesus
how about you beat Roy how you how about
you good I think sports season is back
my man we can finally talk about yes we
also will take over this which sport is
your favorite NBA basketball back for a
week
Lexie's night I just talked to myself
about basketball right as a kid during
the Michael Jordan I think he was so
undeniable everyone [ __ ] watch
basketball then yeah but since him I
don't think that's ever been is like
[ __ ] an electrifying Newt no like I
don't know do you find three-pointers
electrifying of course yeah now it's
like everybody's you can see Wow offense
versus all people got better I gotta say
four years changed the game
I think the difference between Michael
Jordan any of the stars today though is
the on and off the court he's in movies
his influence it outside he was damn
yeah like his his influence outside it's
not like Muhammad Ali I like my or Bruce
Lee like just the greats is Allah knows
and a bunch of Insurance commercials
he's not playing right that's exactly
the problem he's in Gold Bond
commercials are you listening to
yourself
he wasn't that and then I see ha yeah
everything we decide that he's doing
more commercials the cat's-eye is the
brand deal horn yeah [ __ ]
she was on the song he sells everything
except for extra-large beds which is the
only thing I've ever seen him have
that's unique he sells everything else
for regular-sized people [ __ ] nut
LeBron's trying to do that though
LeBron's in a new Space Jam yeah but
LeBrons China policy is no can't get
behind its policy I know that's what's
that's what's interesting about the NBA
this season I know it's weird to talk
about politics about it I'm not really
let's get there because football has
already been there but yeah now the NBA
is into politics and you have LeBron
who's like the squeaky clean like more
than an athlete person backing up you
know a communist regime so it's like
he's back up his pockets mainly the best
[ __ ] is what he's like he's like yo I'm
more than just a basketball player and
then he's like and then people are like
hey what you think about China he's like
hey I'm just the basketball player if
his agenda wasn't like oh I opened this
school cuz I you know which is it
obviously it's a positive but like I
don't know it's like a double-edged
sword I guess but like ya on the other
side he is like trying to be more than
an athlete because of the whole quote of
like some like right journalist said
like just shut up and dribble told the
Brawn not to go into politics yeah Laura
Ingraham and and yeah a lot of people
had a problem with that and I did too
but then hearing LeBron say I'm just a
basketball player exactly he's just
shutting up and dribbling yeah so right
so you can't hide behind it and also
like pick your head up and go like
that's what I think people want to fight
for their rights until it [ __ ] with
their salary I just wish that people
would go like yo here's my thing about
China yeah they'll be tired of you guys
think has the capacity to do John
Witherspoon and he just passed away
today um he would he would see me all
kinds of [ __ ] interviews and [ __ ] and
he would be like I just love money like
what you think about doing the Friday's
like it was fun he's like we didn't pay
me enough I wanted more money like he's
just very honest you couldn't be
couldn't be more honest yeah I think
yeah is Tony sailing huh me 77 Wow he's
just old that's not all
is that I mean you know I had 37 I feel
like nowadays is young is it there's a
lot plummet 70s to 80s is 70s is like
you're starting to see the light at the
end of the tunnel and what I mean but
it's like you still got a few years
under your belt he's a [ __ ] legend man
it is like ah yeah I think like 85 and
older I'm like I got it
don't sleep on those 70 year olds though
cuz I got somebody in my karate club at
77 and you wouldn't even know that he
said I'm like what really does it look
like ads and [ __ ] I'm like you're not
even on steroids how is that even
possible
Jun rewear I was in karate when I wasn't
yeah yeah yeah jewelry he's a jewelry
karate and he it was a person's name
look at things you read you know he wore
a golden like [ __ ] karate gear and he
and he would and he would make us all
watching my satin a thousand push-ups
before we got to do our turns like 80
years old yeah he's like eight years old
has [ __ ] all the [ __ ] packs [ __ ]
abs and is still alive no he passed away
a couple years me it was 81 you as a kid
yeah alright yeah so but he we would all
I remember my parents and they're like
dear parents at there yeah we all put
they all had to go get tight none of my
prints were at any of my [ __ ] well I was
five buddy if they dropped your ass off
at five and left you they were true well
my old man wasn't there my mom was there
okay my uh my dad would always drop me
off to do like a kung fu but he'd be the
reason why I always get punished cuz I
you know you coat go down the line and
you do a [ __ ] round houses were like
punches or whatever my dad would be that
I like oiler
I'm like making me laugh so I'm like
punching and I'm like start laughing and
the seafood would come and then he'd be
like why the [ __ ] are you [ __ ] I can't
really wrap my dad I'm just say [ __ ] son
of a [ __ ]
I'll go down the line again in all the
pears oil I would have been like my mom
yeah and then they're all sitting there
and I go down the line again he's like
you're doing cross-eyed and just random
chatter like
doing random things like this do you
like watching you get in trouble this is
like you're getting the [ __ ] Bronze
Star and everyone's [ __ ] gathered
around your debt your old man's gone
he's like that's a lot dude yeah back
then but I think now looking back that's
pretty funny do you think you'll do the
same for TECA no because he cares about
yeah I want I want him to do to do good
I don't know why my dad thought was
funny but would you want to talk or play
football [ __ ] I don't know cuz with all
the CTE stuff yeah
like cuz there's a part of me that
really wants him to do anything he wants
high school yeah if you wanna take some
but let's say he's killing in high
school and he's like mom dad I have a
chance to go pro I wanna go to college
and they're saying they're saying people
that are really good in high school and
college already have the same amount of
CTE as NFL football yeah my god yeah cuz
you already playing out that look you're
not playing like a [ __ ] 130 pound
Asian kid like you know they're already
hitting the Samoans the black people
that are like [ __ ] 250 280 even the
research that like the case study on
those people he's not gonna give a [ __ ]
about that no that's like parents that
are like don't ride motorcycles serious
dads yeah and you're like I don't go
[ __ ] I'll write it anyway true like when
you rub your eyes you get it we see you
second but do I have it right now yeah
you look like a [ __ ] demon oh
absolutely
if they want if they really wanted to
I'm not gonna well I'm not gonna be the
dad or the more likely you think you're
to say is anything in in in your
relationship I think Nikki's gonna deter
well no I'm saying well I don't think we
want to be the parents who are like no
you cannot do that you've also tied a
lot of the CTE to depression suicidal
thoughts and domestic abuse like a lot
of the football depression suicidal
thoughts also happen without all anyone
very true but there's a lot of football
players that there's a link where
they're being the [ __ ] other wives
because of the CTE all right think that
a lot of football players want to blame
SETI does cause a lot of violet and and
weird personality disorders yeah yeah
but dude like Ray Rice with in the
elevator there's a lot there's a lot of
[ __ ] though like if he's girlfriend you
see that you guys see that video he beat
this [ __ ] out it's crazy and then he's
probably of course he's probably like oh
[ __ ] CT [ __ ] being up
what did she say what did she say
exactly Ranchers was it says something
really mean yeah she probably did yeah
she's probably like what I [ __ ] dumpy
ass elevator and he's like what you
saying yeah yeah it's like I think that
paid for us to come here I thought this
is nice but yeah you guys think
football's a dying sport no [ __ ] no like
maybe in like 50 years save is not what
you want no no I think that there's I
heard it makes a lot of honey
statistically every year it's making
less and less true money ya know they
say it's not America's sport anymore
just well they say that about baseball
but they still make some a [ __ ] ton of
money baseball's losing baseball baby is
what you're talking it's just Americans
watching American football no well
they're they expanded in the UK recently
really soccer over there they do but
there's that there's a group I mean dude
it's it's actually the Superbowl gets
viewed worldwide so you have to
recognize that there's they're trying to
get it more integrated into European
countries because because they want to
expand their market place but NFL is a
[ __ ] worldwide it's a phenomenon dude
I like the rookies retired you're
laughing I don't think you're as read on
this as you think okay so cuz you even
know about the UK [ __ ] invested because
we play as kids right it's in our high
schools our middle schools UK they're
just watching as a spectator that it's
not they don't they play football I mean
something about soccer exactly we don't
watch soccer no we think it's up but
they probably think footballs gay I
don't think they do I don't think they
do except for when some tackles look
kind of gay
probably I'm just being try to be
respectful in what oh well what about
those rookies retiring
you know they enter one year in NFL and
then they retire because of the whole CT
yeah that's up to that man I mean look
everything's a dice roll I mean I mean
if you're doing football you're putting
your body on the line every [ __ ] week
no matter what what if your kid wants to
be like a stunt driver or a special ops
military person or there's Jesse welder
brother saying well that's one of the
top dangers down yeah yeah that and a
crab fisherman that's even worse that
shit's like one of the most dangerous
jobs in the world I just don't wanna be
the person who's standing in my kid's
way if they want to do
because for craps you don't want to keep
you don't want your kids let's see
that's that's not one of the common
defenses that I think parents use is
like well I'm just troubled I'm trying
to look out for your safety and it's
like whatever mom slam door you know I'm
saying like like [ __ ] like that I don't
want to be that but don't you want to
control and brainwash them of course but
in a different way
okay well I don't know maybe science
could advance to a point where like they
can prevent it with the type of helmets
and [ __ ] that they have the prevent the
CTE stuff good yeah like if it does
really make that much money then I'm
pretty sure they're investing a lot of
money into research to prevent where
they are now because they were
reasonably strong-armed into it by Will
Smith by Will Smith because these guys
these guys are just too crazy these guys
are like 300 pounds moving like all the
big sprinter the helmet needs to be like
this the speed that you guys are dark
out a dark helmet oh my god juggernaut
is running around it's like big heads
they used to do it an NBA Jam when we
were kids oh yeah yeah people are
getting CT because you're getting hit
when they're not knowing you know you're
sprinting this way you think no one is
is is even close to you and out of
nowhere you get t-boned full speed when
the people are getting concussions they
don't even know where they get hit from
they're just in the air and they're like
oh [ __ ] and then they're [ __ ] they
scorpion backwards and they're all
[ __ ] what I can't believe sometimes is
I watch like a [ __ ] receiver go up
like four feet to catch a ball he gets
hit from behind does a [ __ ] full flip
lands on his head and then everyone's
like oh [ __ ] and then he just gets up
I'm like Jesus it's crazy these guys are
[ __ ] psychos man they're frequent the
goal is to have a lot of kids there you
go you lose one to CT you're like
whatever
that's the Abe Lincoln maneuver yeah how
many kids do you have like seven kids
and four died of Cholera yeah yeah
that's about seven kids come on no it's
in those days it's like 10 yeah 13 I
thought was the average I don't think he
had enough cuz none of them are famous I
don't think his bloodline survives are
you right yeah
there was no other famous Lincoln yeah I
didn't know he I thought he died without
kids
well Andrew Lincoln's descendants and
there's one that's like yeah I don't
know I got carrying all you know who the
[ __ ] related to Lincoln who [ __ ] uh
not did I told you is that Alec Baldwin
no you tell me some actor in Hollywood
is like three three generations away
from Lincoln Wow at the end of the day
it all resulted ah oh wow how about that
what can we do about it
marriage brother Andrew Lincoln from the
walking dead but I don't think he's
willing to like that Louis so you know
it's still like on it's not like
elevenses it's on HBO it just released
that they're doing their Game of Thrones
spinoff yeah what is it House of dragons
they killed the deal me Harris one they
killed in a yes per transaction thoughts
on tighter but who's Naomi Harris you
don't know her hair she's been in James
Bond movie she's played Moneypenny no
wait so what's the house of dragons is
it a prequel I think it's three hundred
years before
the Targaryen Aryan and the author a
book george RR martin is credit as
producer it's a [ __ ] pretty cool so
pretty cool break my [ __ ] balls do
you don't like it it's like an origin
story no but it's just like man there's
no the stakes are different i hope they
follow characters that we've never seen
before we don't know about I wanna see a
pre-k but that we don't know about like
we never even heard about the lineage of
like that whatever the [ __ ] but don't
you want to investigate them the prequel
prequel to the original yeah like did
you ever watch like uh x-men origins at
Wolverine yeah complete ass it's [ __ ]
tight you see how you cable it was it's
one of the worst movies maybe ever made
you didn't like him when he had bones
coming up before yeah oh you didn't like
Oh remember that I remember Deadpool in
that movie when he said like
don't know what with silver samurai oh
yeah they they but they didn't just [ __ ]
on x-men origins Wolverine Palestine oh
my god or save themselves with Logan
though yeah well yeah they finally made
a good Wolverine movie at the [ __ ]
end
Logan's gets you yeah buddy I'm gonna
[ __ ] shut it here and be moved in
this one like it's expected that it's
supposed to be just for my [ __ ] it's
here an end game I don't want to do much
it cuz taiko [ __ ] I don't really
care either I was just from that yeah I
had your back I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry I didn't even see I didn't even
see or hear you obviously when I think
about prequels Monken you don't even
believe us I think footballs dying
I know Bart but it's the pre quarter
football and rugby no it's a soccer
player well yeah what will take its
place that's what I'm saying a real
football boy means gonna take its place
Eastbourne gaming yeah eSports gonna
take its place it might be the biggest
Super Bowl oh man it already this I
heard they sell out good football
brother it is you got nuts man the
average game is no it was on the new it
was it was there was an article this
year about how more people tuned in to
the streaming event then the Superbowl
and they made more ad dollars in a Super
Bowl that's different I'm talking about
the money it makes in a year compared to
[ __ ] I don't know it might yeah it's
no way with merch and all [ __ ] and
ticket sales yeah I don't know I got a I
got a look at the number I say
interesting place but I think it's gonna
I think it's gonna make more though I
think it's just a matter of time yeah I
feel like we're living in a pussy-ass
world though since that games is taking
over well some of the guys who played
Madden online are pretty badass yeah if
I can go dude
oh yeah I got them in the nickel I'm
gonna run over the [ __ ] corner here
oh oh you know what's gonna happen
[ __ ] Bionic people's that's the
that's the next level right there we're
gonna make Bionic people play the sports
for us you know we're gonna make our
kids by arms yeah I beat down with the
Bionic sports league yeah
yeah it's like gaming and it's like
humans [ __ ] like straight up going in
there to do steroids now stories use
allowing I love that shirt I would be
there for every single I would be a
football fan I'd be a [ __ ] this
awesome can you imagine a guy walking
out looking like [ __ ] Bane from the
Batman movie and he's about to hit a
[ __ ] baseball who would Hogan and all
them I'm like okay and if they live
injected it with more steroids just
[ __ ] Olympics is probably gonna be
the way the best [ __ ] ever
[Music]